the AFI Achievement Award carpet just
got super regal I mean JJ Abrams George
Lucas and Steven Spielberg all posed for
a photo together to honor John Williams
watching him talked to the orchestra is
a a lesson in expression it's a lesson
in communication and as a director I
learned a lot watching him talk to the
orchestra I was amazed by how gentle and
kind and humble he is and he was like
that every day we work together and I it
was one of the most remarkable
experiences of the entire experience
would you be able to choose a favorite
new song out the force weight of a South
practice they work you yeah uh well too
I i love it all the 2 q's i love i think
the most are raised theme and he did a
theme for the resistance it's the
resistance
he actually gave me the that score bound
like in this leather bound book he gave
me the ritual score of that I have the
CD in my car and I just listened to it
yes it's in my car I notice enjoyed net
crime Jedi steps in finale is that most
amazing you do to get I steps did not
get what's so slow and so beautiful
that's amazing i'm like like doing
that's amazing
I will tell you that that piece of music
is that's not in the entire movie until
the end that one Q and it's such a
powerful q you know an amazing thing
that it doesn't exist until the very
last scene
what's the first john wayne song you
heard before force awakens that made you
cry as we offer life there are so many i
mean i guess the first one that made me
cry what was was the force theme when
luke is looking out at the binary sunset
it's just it's it's unbearably emotional
it's also my favorite it's incredible
you are an amazing man you rule thank
you so much for your kindness thank you